I call this your money autobiography,
andas a money coach, this is
the first step I take with my clients.
Think back toyour earliest
childhood money memory.
What did it feel like
when you got money?
Were you excited, proud or confused?
And what did you do
with the money?
Did you runto the candy store,
or did you run to the bank?
And what did you hear
your parents say,
and what did you see your
parents do with the money?
Change is difficult,
but in myfamily, not
changing is fatal.
So I did the work,
and I have experienceddeep
and profound forgiveness.
It only takes one person in your family
to break through the
money-shame cycle.
I want you to be the one.